I'm gonna brown james's it hey what's up
I'm Nietzsche I'm a tasty producer and
it seems like everybody is obsessed with
the fried chicken sandwich but I think
that there's a fried chicken sandwich
it's super underrated it's the fried
chicken biscuit you have a thick
flavorful piece of fried chicken on top
of a warm buttery flaky biscuit it's
absolutely delicious but sometimes I
don't want to wait in line for hours
just to get a breakfast sandwich so I'm
gonna make my own version and see how
homemade stacks against fast food all
right so we're gonna start with
seasoning our chicken it's just
something very simple just salt and
pepper make sure you get both sides I
like a nice flavorful piece of chicken
we're using chicken thighs they are
really juicy and kind of thick cuts of
chicken so if you maybe overcook it a
little bit you're not gonna know this as
much so I'm going to load our chicken
into the bag where we're gonna pour our
marinade first thing I'm gonna add
buttermilk here next I'm gonna be adding
pickle juice and this might seem weird
but it adds a really really nice tang to
the chicken this smells delicious okay
so make sure you want to spread out all
of those flavors and get your chicken
completely coated and your marinade here
we're gonna let it sit overnight so you
guys are on so it's time to make the
biscuit of our fried chicken biscuit in
my favorite part we're gonna start with
adding flour baking powder baking soda
and salt so we're gonna whisk our dry
ingredients together to make sure that
they are fully incorporated we're gonna
add our cold butter into our fully
incorporated dry mixture here and then I
am just going to toss this together so
that the butter is fully coated and then
I'm gonna use a pastry blender to cut
this up if you don't have a pastry
blender a fork is totally fine
I wouldn't recommend using your hands
because if you don't use it quick enough
your brother is gonna get too warm and
that's not exactly what we're looking
for we're gonna cut this about pea-sized
the bigger your butter is the flakier
your biscuit is gonna be so once you get
to a sandy texture here you're pretty
much done and then you can go ahead and
core
create your buttermilk make sure you
pour it slowly because when you pour it
slowly you can make sure that the dough
gets kind of wet evenly without having
to overwork it and we're smarter not
harder people I'm just gonna incorporate
this in just make sure all of our dough
is nice and hydrated great so this looks
perfect nice shaggy texture which is
exactly what we're looking for so now I
think I'm ready to start forming my
biscuits to get started I'm gonna
sprinkle some flour out on the surface
where our dough is gonna go to prevent
it from sticking
then we're gonna dump the dough right on
top of that my favorite part let's make
them this you just want to kind of bring
this together and form it before you
start rolling it just kind of turn the
dough into one big blob if you will you
want to work it just to the point where
it starts to come together
a good biscuit dough you don't want to
overwork it so did its ace tender when
we're cooking great so I think she's
just about coming together here we're
gonna put a little bit more flour on the
surface before we row it out make sure
you put some flour on your rolling pin
as well because it's gonna help with
sticking so we're looking to get this
about an inch thick and I think we're
about good I'm gonna use a three inch
cookie cutter to cut the biscuits now
make sure you dip this in the flour
because remember you don't want it to
stick and then we're just gonna cut out
six biscuits look how perfect this is
like I'm so excited so to make this so
if you're losing your dough a little bit
just bring it back to its shape and then
roll it out so about it inch again and
keep cutting your biscuits so these
biscuits are looking absolutely perfect
before I put them in the oven I'm gonna
brush the tops of them with butter and
then we're gonna add some flaky salt to
them as well so our biscuits are done
all we need to do is put them in the
oven at 375 degrees Fahrenheit for about
12 to 15 minutes and then we can get
started on our chicken now let's time to
make the breading for my chicken I am
going to combine some flour baking
powder which is great to make sure that
your chicken is really crunchy and stays
crunchy
we've got some onion powder and some
garlic powder and then of course some
salt we're gonna whisk all of our dry
ingredients together make sure it's all
nice and incorporated we're gonna add
our buttermilk in but only a little bit
at a time because it's going to
make sure that this mixture here flakes
up and what happens in is you're gonna
get some really nice pockets of crunch
on your chicken when you fry it and this
is what it's supposed to look like nice
and clumpy and now we're ready to dip
our chicken in so a normal dredge is
usually when you go from flour two eggs
of flour and then directly to frying but
we're not gonna do that here we're gonna
do a little bit of an untraditional
method which is we're gonna take our
chicken here that's already been
marinating already nice and wet and
that's gonna serve as kind of the
binding that the egg would serve is make
sure you press it in to make sure that
it sticks as you can see we've got these
extra little flakes here and they're
gonna get nice and crispy when you fry
it that's exactly what we want all right
so now we're ready to fry our chicken
we've got our oil here Heat it's at 350
degrees Fahrenheit and we are going to
start frying our chicken in batches all
right so when you're putting it in just
make sure you put it in away from you
the sound of chicken frying is like one
of the greatest sounds known to man so I
can already see my chicken is kind of
starting to get nice and gold we're
gonna let this go for five to seven
minutes or until the internal
temperature reaches 165 degrees
Fahrenheit so I'm just gonna use the
spider here to kind of push the chicken
around and make sure that it's cooking
evenly and they're not getting kind of
clumped together all right these are
looking absolutely beautiful I'm gonna
take it out and remember I said we want
to make sure that our internal
temperature is at 165 degrees so I'm
gonna use my little gadget here to make
sure that we are perfectly at 165 which
we are so we're gonna go ahead and take
the rest of our chicken out Wow look at
this look how perfectly like just golden
this is looking absolutely beautiful
you got those nice crunchy pieces on the
top I'm gonna hit these pieces with a
little bit more salt while they're still
hot just a little bit oh right this is
looking absolutely beautiful pretty
excited we got super perfectly crispy
golden brown chicken over here and over
here we got some thick homemade flaky
biscuits so when we bring these things
together just
in your mouth we're just gonna cut our
biscuit in half now I'm gonna brush one
side with butter and then we're gonna
put a piece of chicken on it you go for
medium size and then we're gonna close
it on top here and uh guys that's a
chicken biscuit it looks gorgeous you
can add other toppings to this pickle of
Mayo slaw
guess it depends on when you want to
have it how about we see how it stacks
up against the competition huh we are
here with my friend David he is going to
be our taste tester and I've got two
chicken biscuit sandwiches for you
looking at these my first glance I'm
thinking like it reminds me of like good
burger like this was the you know
regular chicken patties and they
sprinkled this one was some magical and
kind of made it twice the size they put
a little pie out right there a little
pile on the top I like that I'm going to
get into it let's see try this one out
first
I gotta say it's good it was definitely
crispy like you said kind of has like
that crunch you want and the biscuit but
it was still soft the chicken was good I
had that like that's unfamiliar taste
but I can't even really put it together
quite yet I'm interested to see what's
going on with the big boy that's a great
bite this is what I want when I want
like a chicken biscuit like this one was
good you know had like that crispy kind
of crunchy flavor light airy biscuit but
when I bit into this one I could almost
feel the extra butter that I would put
in all my recipes that are not supposed
to so I'm glad to hear that this one's
your favorite because this one's
actually from chick-fil-a wow that's
really good I mean this is like really
good this one I do have to say is just a
little bit better like they're both
amazing but this one just takes the cake
for me so we're staying in as opposed to
like driving up oh yeah we're staying in
for sure I'm actually gonna go ahead and
take this opportunity to do a little bit
more market research I hope you know
this goes well yeah seems like thanks
well there you guys have it our home
eight parts chicken biscuit in a blind
taste test wins out against the fast
food fried chicken biscuit fast food was
really great in a pinch but if you got a
little bit of extra time I really
recommend you guys trying this out it's
absolutely delicious if there are any
other fast foods you want us to try make
sure you leave it in a comment
below and we will see you guys next time
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]